Superpowered farts and an island of mutated
beasts don't make for an easy trip down
memory lane. Not even a vanishing spell can
wipe these box office flops from history.
The late British actor John Hurt played a number
of iconic parts in his long career, with key roles
in classic fantasy and sci-fi franchises like
"Doctor Who," "Alien," "Hellboy," and of course
the "Harry Potter" films, where he played
Garrick Ollivander. But there's at least one
film he starred in back in the '90s that failed
to take hold and become the next big sci-fi film,
instead becoming a flop. That
was the 1993 movie "Monolith."
The film focuses on a pair of police officers
who are investigating the passing of a young boy
when they stumble across a possible alien
invader with the ability to shapeshift.
Hurt portrays the government agent who
wants them to leave the case alone.
Though it does have some genuinely intriguing
ideas, it all comes across so generic and
ham-fisted that it becomes a whole lot of
nothing. Bad direction, bland characters,
a confusing script … We've seen it all before in
bad B-movies that were better than this. Hurt is
certainly capable of playing a chilling, even
terrifying villain, but he's woefully miscast
in "Monolith" and would probably have
wanted us to forget he was ever in it.
Helena Bonham Carter would join
the "Harry Potter" series in
"The Order Of The Phoenix" and return for its
three sequels as the villainous Death Eater
Bellatrix Lestrange. It was a part that seems
like it was tailor made for the frenetic actress.
One-time partner of Tim Burton, she has also
starred in more than a half-dozen of his films,
including "Planet of the Apes," "Alice
in Wonderland," and "Dark Shadows."
Across her career she's ventured into just about
every genre and dozens of acclaimed movies. But
if she could wipe one of them from existence, it
has to be the strange dental comedy "Novocaine."
The film is about a dentist who gets framed for
murder after an encounter with alluring patient,
played by Carter, who seduces him and turns
his life upside down. A tonal mish-mash,
the movie dances between black comedy and
outright parody, making one increasingly
numb to its ambitious premise. Whether it's
supposed to be a genuinely suspenseful thriller or
a comic farce you're never quite sure, but when
it's all over you just want to rinse and spit.
"You see, that's the nature of attraction.
You find yourself doing things
and you have no idea why."
Before "Harry Potter," Alan Rickman already
had several well-known roles under his belt,
including the Sheriff of Nottingham
in "Robin Hood: Prince of Thieves"
and the villainous Hans Gruber in the
action classic "Die Hard." But he'd reach
a new stratosphere in the "Harry Potter" series
portraying the dark, enigmatic Professor Snape,
a wizard who seemed to blur the line between
good and evil. Already a Hollywood fixture,
the role further cemented Rickman
as one of Hollywood's finest stars.
But Rickman wasn't without his duds, and
few can measure up to the disappointment
of "Mesmer," a bizarre biopic about Franz Anton
Mesmer. Mesmer was a doctor who peddled his
theories in hypnosis and mystical energies in
the 18th century. The result is a film that's
about what you'd expect from a period drama based
on a forgotten figure in pseudoscience history,
even if Rickman is his usual
charismatic self in the title role.
Still, the actor alone often can't
save a film, though he tried.
"That's very kind of you."
Before Ralph Fiennes played a heroic,
old-fashioned superspy in "The King's Man,"
the actor who starred in "Harry Potter" as Lord
Voldemort led a flop called "The Avengers." It's
a movie that Fiennes and pretty much everyone
else involved would be thrilled to forget,
as it is one of the most notorious film failures
of the '90s. Not only was it a box office dud,
but it also came into theaters with high
expectations and was absolutely terrible,
wasting a star-studded cast and all its potential.
Fiennes played secret agent John Steed
in this big budget adaptation of the
hit British television series of the same
name. But despite having all the ingredients
to be the next big action franchise, "The
Avengers" was a total disaster and a clumsy,
charmless film that didn't exactly electrify
the box office like its MCU namesake.
Fiennes himself slammed the
movie, telling The Guardian:
"You don't go to work thinking
you're going to make a bad film.
I went to work thinking, 'Great,
let's reinvent 'The Avengers,''
which I loved as a kid. It's only
now ... that we look back and groan."
Actor Tom Felton came to fame thanks to his
casting in "Harry Potter," though he'd had a
few roles before joining the J.K. Rowling epic.
After leaving Hogwarts, Felton struggled to
achieve the same success as the franchise's trio
of young stars. One film he took on in the wake
of "Harry Potter" that he almost certainly
regrets is the horror movie "Night Wolf."
A film that takes itself way more seriously
than it should, "Night Wolf" centers on a
group of teens in a cliched situation: stuck
inside a house during a dark and stormy night.
One by one, they get picked off by a
mysterious creature: a werewolf. Of course
this comes as a complete shock to audiences
who didn't look at the title of the movie,
or pick up the very obvious clues that the
filmmakers probably thought were ever-so-clever.
Felton plays the stock stoner character
Gary, one of the beast's first victims,
so if you are checking this one
out because you love Draco Malfoy,
don't expect to see much of him. He might be
glad he didn't have to stick around for the
film's entire shoot, but he probably wishes he
hadn't been there at all. At least he was smart
enough to not return for the director's
next movie, "Strippers vs. Werewolves."
"I bet you loved that, didn't you, Potter?"
Joining Hogwarts for "Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire," actor Brendan Gleeson played Mad Eye
Moody, who is at first the disguise of Barty
Crouch Jr. In subsequent films, Gleeson returns as
the real Mad Eye, and helps Potter defeat the Dark
Lord Voldemort. A renowned Irish character actor,
Gleeson's career goes all the way back to the late
'80s and he's gone on to feature in classics like
"Into The West," "Braveheart," and "28 Days
Later." His career also has its flops though,
and one actioner may be the film
the actor would love us all to skip.
Though it boasted a decent cast, "Turbulence"
is decidedly not a '90s classic, no matter
what the filmmakers lofty ambitions may have
been. In the film, Gleeson stars as Stubbs,
a bank robber being transported by plane alongside
another diabolical criminal named Weaver,
who manages to break free of his U.S.
Marshal escort and take over the flight.
It may have been a compelling starting premise,
but with flat performances and unimpressive
stunts, "Turbulence" crashed and burned. The
film's stark similarities to "Con Air," released
the same year, definitely didn't help matters
either. Gleeson spared himself the indignity
of appearing in the two direct-to-video
sequels, which were somehow even worse.
"...what?"
A member of the Order of the Phoenix,
Remus Lupin started out as a mysterious
figure in his first appearance, with many
believing that it was he, in werewolf form,
who had been terrorizing Hogwarts. But after
the culprit was revealed to be Peter Pettigrew,
Lupin became one of the greatest
heroes of the Second Wizarding War.
He was played by actor David Thewlis, who outside
of "Harry Potter" has had plenty of hit films.
But the disaster "The Island of Dr. Moreau" was
most certainly not among them. A historically bad
film, it was led by Marlon Brando as the eponymous
doctor, and boasted a star-studded cast. But
it's Thewlis who sparks the film's story, as his
character crash lands on the island and discovers
the experiments of the demented Moreau, who is
creating bizarre, mutated half-human creatures.
Thankfully, the film's failure
doesn't rest on Thewlis' shoulders.
That's down to Brando's laziness,
the film's haphazard construction,
and a muddled and meandering story. But
perhaps most importantly, it's just plain
boring. If Thewlis could back out of this
one retroactively, we have no doubt he would.
"This is the most outrageous spectacle I
have ever witnessed. Look at yourself!"
Actress Imelda Staunton went from little-known
character actor to most-hated woman in households
everywhere when she gave her first
performance as the prudish professor
Dolores Umbridge. But just four years before she
came to fame in the Wizarding World, Staunton
made a little film she now probably wishes she
could make disappear, "The Virgin of Liverpool."
You'd be forgiven for thinking this one
was a groan-worthy adult comedy given
its title and place on this list, but it's
actually about a statue of the Virgin Mary.
The film centers on a young girl who discovers
the statue when it is being discarded by a priest
during renovations of his church. While her family
is annoyed by the statue she brings home, it gets
attention from the community for apparently
performing an active miracle in a chip shop.
Aspiring to be a sappy sentimental family
movie, it ends up a groaner of a story that
looks incredibly cheap. So it comes as no surprise
to learn that the filmmakers made the movie just a
few weeks after finding a random script on the
internet. Thankfully, it wasn't bad enough to
prevent Staunton from being cast as one of Harry
Potter's most delightfully loathsome characters.
"Deep down, you deserve to be
punished, don't you, Mr. Potter."
Even more renowned than Dame Maggie Smith, Sir
Richard Harris led the first two "Harry Potter"
pictures as the wise, gentle wizard Dumbledore
before the star's unfortunate passing. But decades
before he stepped onto Hogwarts' grounds, Harris
appeared in some of Hollywood's finest films, from
classics like "The Guns of Navarone" and "Mutiny
on the Bounty" to modern greats like "Unforgiven"
and "Patriot Games." But of course, like everyone
else on this list, he's got at least one that he
would take back if he could. In Harris' case,
it's the adventure movie, "Tarzan, The Ape Man."
A modern reinterpretation of the classic novel by
Edgar Rice Burroughs, the film is not the rousing,
tree-swinging adventure fans might have wanted
or even expected. That's because oddly enough,
Tarzan himself isn't even the star of the movie,
with the story instead focusing on his female
companion Jane, and Harris playing her father
here. With Bo Derek cast in the role of Jane,
the producers turned the film into
little more than softcore titillation.
It's packed with enough uncomfortable adult
situations to make even John Waters blush.
Derek was impressed with Harris'
professionalism and performance,
despite the horrid script. She
even told Entertainment Weekly:
"The picture was doomed. [...] But
Richard gave it his all anyway."
Just 11 years old when he was cast as Ron Weasley
in "Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone,"
Rupert Grint hasn't achieved the same level of box
office stardom as his co-star Emma Watson. Nor has
he appeared in highly acclaimed arthouse films
like Daniel Radcliffe. He's preferred instead
to stick to roles in prestige television projects,
such as "The ABC Murders" with John Malkovich and
"Snatch," a series adapted from the Guy Ritchie
film. But back when he was just getting started
in "Harry Potter," Grint also starred in another
children's fantasy film: "Thunderpants," which
is about a boy who can't stop farting. Needless
to say, it didn't become a cinematic classic.
While Grint does not take the title role in
"Thunderpants," he does play the best friend,
a child scientist who helps the tooter
deal with his worrisome wind-breaking.
In fairness to Grint, this ridiculous romp
isn't all that terrible. It's a fairly fun
children's flick that will at least leave you
laughing from the ludicrous light-hearted gags.
But with Grint attempting a more
serious and dramatic career,
this can't be a movie he's proud to
trot out for his new fans to watch.